the eu's consumer protection laws look
set to get stronger
parliament will vote on legislation to
allow consumer rights groups to take
legal action on behalf of victims of the
same rights infringement
millions of civil court cases in the eu
have cross-border implications
meps will vote on new rules making the
sharing of legal documents within the eu
easier through digitization and
decentralized i.t systems
what if tablets computers and mobile
phones were easier to fix parliament is
set to call for consumers to have a
right to repair
prolonging the lifespans of consumer
products ending programmed obsolescence
and increasing sustainability
as europe recovers from the pandemic and
moves towards climate neutrality
industries will have to adapt meps are
set to call on the commission to come up
with a revised industrial strategy
to boost research and development of new
technologies and support europe's
industries
through the green and digital
transitions
meps are concerned about a growing
pattern of intimidation against
journalists in the eu
parliaments will vote on a resolution
calling for reporters to be better
protected for the independence of public
media
and a framework to stamp out hate speech
and disinformation online